c'est une affaire qui a défrayé la
chronique toute la semaine à celle de
denis baupin mise en cause par plusieurs
élus pour harcèlement sexuel
je recevrai ce week-end dans la voix est
libre isabelle apte à la députée du
calvados qui fait partie des victimes
présumées
j'accueillerai également le député les
républicains de la manche guénhaël huet
quel regard porte-t-il sur cette affaire
qui pose la question de la place laissée
aux femmes en politique
et puis je recevrai également alain
morvan le directeur de dcns cherbourg
pour évoquer la construction d'une usine
d'hydroliennes à cherbourg et la
fourniture de sous marins au l'australie
libre c'est samedi à 11h30 sur france 3
monde